alright it looks like we are now live
for the February philosophy pop up the
one on YouTube will also do one on
Facebook live later on this month and I
thought since it's February and you know
it's a month when everybody always ends
up talking about Valentine's Day I would
do something having to do with a recent
actually just today piece that I
published in stoicism today having to do
with stoicism and they're you know the
the ancient Stoics views on love
essentially romantic or erotic love we
would call it and relationships so I
thought I would field some questions we
can certainly talk about many other
things if you want to but I thought that
would be a good topic to begin with let
me take a quick look and see if we we
have any questions already
and I'll start reconfiguring my Windows
here so I can see questions as they're
they're popping up I'm making my screens
a little bit smaller so let me tell you
a little bit about why I wrote the piece
that I did might be interesting to some
people you know there's there's not a
lot of discussion in stoicism about
romantic relationships in general and
you would get the idea I think from a
lot of sort of thumbnail glosses of
stoic authors that they wouldn't really
have that much to do with romance or
dating or any of those sorts of stuff
but people do ask questions quite
frequently on the the stoicism Facebook
group and and you know occasionally in
other forums so it's clearly something
that's of interest and you know our herb
social conventions as far as these
things go have really changed a lot from
ancient times right I mean you do see
stoical authors talking a lot about the
family and marriage and you know
melodious rufus actually has a very nice
discussion about what a
good marriage ought to look like and he
says that it's one we're both partners
are going to be both virtuous and and
they are in it to have kids but they're
also in it for a common life together
you know so there's this this whole
other dimension of intimacy and you know
there's that sort of stuff but how do we
how do we actually make that fit the
kind of relationships that we have today
where you know the divorce rate here in
the United States is 50% and many people
are involved in long-term monogamous
relationships without ever being married
or before they get married there's you
know like a incredible range of
different ways of life one might have in
terms of you know hookup culture
traditional dating and courtship and
everything in between
so you know what would the Stoics
actually have to tell us about that and
I'll just before you know I start
addressing some questions I'll just
mention one thing that you can you can
find in the stoicism Today article and
that is that if you go to some of the
sources that aren't specifically stoic
sources except for the area's didymus as
epitome of stoic ethics and you you read
what they have to say about a rose in
Greek right romantic love we often call
it our erotic love it's interesting
because there's really three different
positions being represented one position
which you see in Diogenes lair tase's
look this is just one of the the
passions or emotions it's not a good
thing the wise person isn't going to
feel this sort of erotic desire or
erotic affection towards anybody and
that's one way to look at it it's like a
you know disturbance the way many of the
other non you Pathak emotions are right
and at the other extreme we have what
areas didymus says which is that there's
there's really two kinds of arrows one
is this you know sort of pathological
love and the other is going to be felt
by the wise and as a matter of fact the
why
as somebody who actually has all the
virtues is going to have in utero TK
automate a right in addition to also
having like a you know dialect DK honor
teh and some potiki RDA which is you
know translate is convivial virtue but
they're gonna have an erotic virtue so
that it's it's actually not just
permissible but would seem to be you
know it fits in there and and the Stoics
had a consistent definition of love that
was probably coming from these these
texts that we don't have anymore clay
anthias wrote quite a few books that
have to do with log or marriage
so did spanish wrote one there's another
guy contemporary of clay at these one of
xenos first students will also wrote
dialogues on love and the Stoics defined
the good kind of love is sort of an
impression of beauty that that sort of
leads to Friendship
and so I think that actually you know
fits fits in there you it's almost like
what's going on in Plato's symposium in
some some places and then in the middle
we have Cicero who says yeah there's
these two kinds of love but you got to
be super careful because a lot of times
what we're what we're construing is the
better kind of love actually isn't so
all right let me take a look at some of
the questions that we've got here that
looked quite interesting
oops scroll through these okay waiting
for the live chat to load itself back up
oh there's quite a few so would a stoic
sacrifice for love what would he not
sacrifice so this is where we got to
discuss you know what kind of love we
have in mind and and there are a lot of
you know there's this popular conception
well the Greeks had four kinds of love
or three kinds of love they get that
from CS Lewis or Andrews [ __ ] and there
are people like that and if you actually
read act you know Greek text you're
gonna find it's a lot messier than that
it's not quite so straight for it is you
know philia eros agape stormy or and
thing like that they blend into each
other but you can say that there are you
know better and worse kinds of love and
that a stoic might be willing to
sacrifice quite a lot for the better you
know the objects of the better kind of
love and you know when we say the stoic
right are we talking about the Procope
tone the person who's working at things
or this legendary person of the the sage
or the wise person who none of us have
usually ever met you know plenty of
Procope toy would would probably
sacrifice quite a bit for erotic love
and then they would say afterwards wow
that was kind of a bad idea no they
would feel regret or remorse about that
there's actually a wonderful discussion
not just about love itself but also
about regret in Margaret Gray vers
stoicism and emotion really really
excellent work but it's an academic work
let me look at the next one if I've read
lakhan's
on Quora and feminine sexuality the
limits of love and knowledge do you
think he has some things to say about
love yeah that kind of has a lot of
things about love I've actually written
on Makai you can find that stuff in my
academia.edu page you know he's somebody
who I've worked with quite a bit and you
don't actually have to go to feminine
sexuality to read that there's some
really great stuff on love and sort of
the development of the concept in the
ethics of psychoanalysis that's that's a
really interesting work probably my
favorite is it's one of his seminars
right so it's not in the crate that's
one of my favorite of all the seminars
surprise surprise you know I'm an
ethicist I like that but yeah I mean he
has a lot of interesting stuff to say
I'll give you sort of a thumbnail of
some of the things so he he does you
know sort of buy into the well you know
the love that
we conceptualize in terms romantic love
does have you know sort of a historical
beginning but he doesn't buy into that
wholesale you see these people are like
you know courtly love only began in the
you know twelfth century or something
some stuff like that and you're like I
don't know do you ever read you know any
of the Latin love poetry you know
because it doesn't seem completely
different from that so you know it's
it's clean and you know of course the
symposium right the notion of the
inaccessible lover and stuff like that
okay that that's you know from from that
courtly love tradition but you know
trying to figure out this crazy emotion
that we feel or emotions perhaps that we
feel and what we ought to do and when we
ought to let you know like obey it or
just you know not obey it and use reason
instead and does a lot of actually
connect up with rationality boy these
are questions that go way way back and
you see them popping up over and over
again so Lacan is attuned to that and he
also he's a critic of a certain kind of
school or not even school let's call it
a movement in psychology that that says
that you know the goal is to like
develop a great you know relationship in
which you know ideally both partners are
gonna have complete satisfaction maybe
even with you know mutual orgasms at the
same time and Lacan is like that's
nonsense you know that's not something
actually to strive after that's gonna
make you nuts to try to use that what
you want to do is sort of figure out you
know with this thing that we call
sexuality which is a mess anyway how to
to come up with a way of making sense of
it and we're doing so sort of already
you know on a trajectory where we've
already you know been screwed up in some
way and it's very much like it I mean
slow ik say something similar not just
about love but about you know life in
general you know when you come to stoic
philosophy or virtue ethics in general
you come as somebody who's already you
know quite a bit damaged
Jen probably has some wrongheaded ideas
that simply reading a book is not going
to you know convince them out of there's
a lived practical component to it a
iterative you know learning from things
process and so you can see you know
virtue ethics and at least certain types
of psychoanalysis or or psychotherapy in
general as doing a similar kind of
project but then you know the question
is well what what what is or the basis
of that alright so there's a question
about a completely different topic and
and the person is addressing me as mr.
Sandler
so it's Adler no and I'm not I'm not a
high school teacher so you don't use the
mr. how do you think we should defend
Peterson I'm not interested in defending
Peterson you know I think Peterson has
enough defenders that I certainly don't
need to take part in that I haven't
gotten around to reading his new rules
for life they may be good they may be
bad I've only read losses on it but you
know he's I'll put it to you this way
he's doing a very different sort of
project than the kind of work that I'm
doing despite the fact that we're both
in what you might call public philosophy
right and so you know I I don't have to
defend Peterson he can defend himself
and he's got all these followers that
I'm sure can can do the work for him a
space fiction what are the Stoics view
on envy bad don't be envious Chris
that's a lot easier said than done isn't
it so that was kind of a joking answer
but so envy is is you know among the
emotions that cause us disturbance and
pain and the Stoics think that that all
emotions ultimately are not just
feelings but involve concepts you could
say they they involve judgments and
usually assumptions and their their
response is tip
way to what are called you know
appearances fantasy also translated as
impressions you can also translate it as
imagination and their ways in which you
could say we're dealing with the world
envy is not from a stoic perspective a
good emotion error there's only a few
emotions that the Stoics actually do
look at as good and very broadly you
know they're they're called that you
pathya and each one of them has sort of
subdivisions but envy doesn't do us any
good it just it just makes us upset and
Epictetus actually has some some great
advice about this in the enchiridion he
says does somebody else get you know
honored above you or get something that
that you didn't get now you know if
that's the case you probably would
naturally feel envious towards that
person he says listen if it's something
good then you can be happy for them that
that's a choice you don't have to feel
like oh I've been deprived because
they've got something and if it's
something bad you know if it's something
that that you're stoic philosophy
actually tells you is not a good thing
then why the hell are you being envious
of them you know maybe you don't
actually believe it all the way or you
haven't sort of worked through the
process and he also says another thing
that I think is really great so he says
you didn't get invited to a dinner party
for example well and I'm gonna be very
crude here in paraphrasing you didn't
kiss-ass
you didn't you know like butter up the
host and and say oh you're such a swell
guy and I really love your food and all
that and epictetus says you didn't pay
the coin so if you don't pay the coin
for something don't be surprised that
you don't get that thing and don't be
upset with other people for getting that
thing they think that like you know
telling somebody all sorts of flattering
things about themself is worth their
time that's their business not not yours
you don't have to worry about that and
and I think that I always find that
advice quite quite helpful myself so so
that that's that's quite good
all right let's see what we got oh
there's a lot of questions now here so
Jarnell lien says I'm studying to become
a teacher secondary school in Belgium
but I'd really like to incorporate
philosophy in my lessons do you have any
ideas or tips on how to do so so that's
actually a great question
I mean there's some subject areas I
think that lend themselves well to
smuggling in some philosophy right so of
course history you know you could just
like gloss over you know in world
history the you know Plato Aristotle
Stoics or you could spend some time on
them and then you know bring in some
some resources English well languages
right grammar and stuff like that
see I'm so used to thinking in an
American style very call it English
class but really literature class right
writing have people read little bits of
philosophical texts and talk about the
ideas and bring them up and and always
you know you don't think of the students
too much because there's this whole
world out there of resources that that
you can direct them to you know so like
you could give them you know like if you
think about Plato's symposium give them
like Aristophanes speech which a lot of
people think is you know Plato's view
anyway they're wrong about that because
it gets presented that way but that's a
good starting point right even in
mathematics classes I'll tell you a
story so this is more about college than
about high school because when I was in
high school I I was very good with math
but I only took the classes I needed to
take to get get done and I found the
classes very boring because the teachers
were very boring and and they didn't
really know how to present the material
well so I got to college and I get put
into a calculus one class just because I
tested well and and it was open and I
needed you know math correct
anyway so my advisor put me in there and
the very first day of class the teacher
started explaining the theory of limits
and I was just fascinated by that and
most of the class hated it of course
because how do you take notes on this
what is it about is this gonna be on the
task they're they're more application
oriented I didn't realize that
mathematics actually had theory behind
it that's how bad the teaching had been
and the theory of limits is really
essentially philosophy right and so you
can you can do that I mean your science
classes your your social studies classes
I think there's ways of bringing in some
some philosophy the the one the one tip
again you don't overwhelm them with too
much stuff they can always they've
always got time to study more you know
the key is to get them interested enough
that they'll keep on digging at it on
their own so that's that is actually a
really great question there's an
interesting one j2b to Nick what made
you stop being at Thomas well I've never
really been a hardcore Thomas to anyway
I think I can dabbled with the idea of
being at Ole Miss back in grad school
but you know part of the problem was the
other Thomas how doctrinaire they could
be and you know how often they were you
know like I'm a Maura tanto mister I
McGarrigle LaGrant all mister I'm at
this tall mist and you'd read there you
talk to them and read their stuff and
you'd be like you know I've read Thomas
Aquinas and he doesn't actually say that
and and you know when it comes down to
it I'm I'm essentially a philosophical
eclectic I'm gonna draw on a number of
different thinkers I would say that I
probably and this is gonna sound a
little bowls full but that that's okay
you know I probably have actually read
and understand more Thomas Aquinas than
many people who call themselves Thomas
just like I I've you know actually read
and applied and and thought about more
stoic stuff than many of the you know
early many of the many of the people who
are like early in their their stoic path
and are identifying themselves as Stoics
but I don't I don't identify myself
wholesale you know I'm much more I mean
if you want somebody who is a toe mist
who's kind of doing something like when
I see myself was doing it be Alistair
McIntyre who you know originally was a
Marxist eventually becomes an
Aristotelian becomes an Augustinian
becomes Thomas and now is more or less
in that that that sort of domain but he
sees Thomism as intrinsically involving
dialogue between traditions and there's
a lot of Thomas who you know they
couldn't they couldn't carry out a
dialogue to save their life they're
they're essentially what we call manual
lists they don't think they've got the
textbook and that's all they need you
know country knows amines this Descartes
failed for this reason so we don't even
have to bother reading up you know
that's I don't really care for that
you've got another question here J to be
two isn't just my yDNA I remember you he
got tested with 23andme what Y DNA did
you get I don't remember was why the I
think why is the father the paternal DNA
I know that I've got some DNA that that
goes back to like the kind of can a rare
and it goes back to the end sort of
aboriginal inhabitants of Europe before
the indo-europeans came through but then
the rest of its all like you know
British / Celtic German and Scandinavian
it was really funny because when we
tested me you know my wife was like well
you got those high cheekbones maybe you
got some Native American and yeah you
know and came back and it's like totally
European then I mean I'm gonna give you
a little digression here too so um a
really funny story after the Trump
election I had a lot of bigots coming
out of the woodwork and like giving me
crazy messages or comments on YouTube
and it all had to do with the fact that
my my name last name Sadler is a Jewish
name
but it's not actually my family made I'm
a actually adopted so there's that right
I'm my adopt I'm my birth family side
I'm basically German Irish with a little
bit of French and British and other
stuff thrown in right and my adoptive
father he was the first one who was born
with the name Sadler in our family
because his grandfather changed it from
scuff cow and he did that because there
was a lot of prejudice against Slavs at
the time so he picked the most English
sounding name he could find and he
settled on Sandler so I'm gonna have
people writing me and be like oh you
know I can tell by your physiognomies
you know you're you're Jewish and you
have Jewish ideas that I'm like wow
you know I mean I you know I'm not gonna
like 23 or me anybody the way I see
people on the white nationalist videos
doing but if I did I'm probably you know
more Arian than them the people that
like that that you know I'm this
degenerate you know essentially because
I've got a family name that that some
Jewish people have and just goes to show
you how much people's assumptions can
color their very perception of say a
facial structure or something like that
really kind of funny there's a great
question from Christian I was wondering
weird no I just just missed it there was
one here we go
what would a stoic look for in a partner
so that is actually a great question and
interestingly I'm gonna again a little
bit of a digression there is a Facebook
group now called stoic dating I have
never looked at it I mean I'm not on the
I'm not dating I got a wife I have no
interest in that sort of thing but I
should take a look at it just to see
what's going on there because I do have
an interest in sort of like keeping
track of what's happening through the
whole stoic sphere you might say what
would a stoic look for in a partner
definitely somebody who shares the same
values
ideally you know you would want somebody
who they may not be committed to
stoicism but you you know would you want
to would you choose to be in a
relationship with somebody who say
thinks that making money is the most
important thing in life or that you know
having the most fashionable clothes or
social connections or something like
that you it would be irrational you'd be
setting yourself up for for so much
conflict you know even if you like we're
like totally you know great with the
person and they never got you you'd be
taking them off all the time because
they they'd be like I don't know what
the hell's wrong with you you know you
don't care about clothes you don't care
about you know who's on American Idol or
whatever other crazy you know pop show
we've got or things like that you know
you're not lining up for the new iPhone
what are what's wrong with you where are
your priorities right so I think you'd
want to find somebody who who you see
you know some some commonalities with
amazonia's Rufus tracks about the need
to cultivate virtue but also to
cultivate this loving disposition
towards each other within a romantic
relationship or in his case he's the
same with a marriage so I think that
that's quite important and you know one
one good place to look I think would be
Epictetus has a a discussion
specifically it's a chapter on
friendship on philia in the discourses I
think it's in book 3 there's a really
good discussion there so that might be a
place to look as well James asked what
are your thoughts on Schopenhauer's s am
love I haven't read it for such a long
time I don't really remember so I'm
sorry but I don't have anything
interesting to say
Alfredo writes what would Stoics think
about nowadays marriage and do they
believe in lifelong love as a couple
yeah they thought that I mean they the
idea was you you enter into this this
relationship and like every other
relationship that comes with a set of
duties and I think some of those duties
would be like you know
to support your partner and work things
out when there's fights and stuff like
that
and we do have a real crisis of marriage
you know the divorce rate is very high
there's many people who aren't divorced
but are in loveless marriages and you
know you can think about what would the
stoic say about that it wasn't totally
unlike that in Roman times either you
know people would would trade up
you know partners or there are some
people that actually like kill their
partners you're plenty of cheating yeah
why does a big penis
use adultery as an example so often
because a lot of people were committing
you know but you know I the the thing I
guess you know you have to think about
why why do you want to marry this person
and are you really in it for good and I
think there's you know you really want
to get to know the person beforehand
before before you get involved so you
can make a prudent choice you know I
remember a friend of mine who ended up
getting divorced in part because his
wife cheated on him
and he was this is before he got married
to her and we were all you know at the
bar after class and we were there with
one of one of our professors who used to
really enjoy taking classes with and
this friend of mine was saying yeah I
don't know I'm I don't know if I want to
marry her or not and the professor said
well don't marry her then okay so but we
are engaged and the professor said yeah
exactly you are engaged that means you
don't have to marry her oh you're in a
period where being engaged doesn't mean
that you are now like sort of pre
married you know it's a time where you
get to sort out whether you really want
to be with this person I think that's
that's kind of good advice space fiction
right have you learned any techniques to
help with motivation for example Mel
Robbins five-second rule I don't know
that that rule techniques to help with
motivation
yeah I mean one thing that I think
really helps is to sort of place things
in in perspective what you you take a
pause and you ask yourself okay why am i
doing XYZ right and that can help you
remind yourself which you know isn't
just cognitive it can also be effective
you can be like oh yeah this is why I
want to do this sort of thing and I have
to do that periodically another thing is
you know keeping things in you might
call it a temporal perspective right
Marcus Aurelius tells us about you know
when things happen
think about the vast sweep of time and
you know about how much has happened and
how much is sort of disappeared and you
can also say wow that's right so I'd
better get on with my work because I
might be dead tomorrow right so that
that could help - right what are some
angles to see Erasmus through more stoic
sources that's a good question I don't
have a good answer because it's been a
while since I've been reading Erasmus so
I don't I don't know I did go to the
library recently and get lip seus who
I'm looking forward to reading you know
another one of these Renaissance people
who's influenced well Erasmus is
influenced by stoicism to some degree
lip seus is a stoic he's a neo stoic so
that's kind of interesting
Sean writes do you think the current
public understanding of post-modernism
is correct or have the mainstream
completely misunderstood the concept
well I don't think there is a current
public understanding of post-modernism
I'd say that there's a there's a lot of
different understandings just like with
most isms you know I think if you were
to go around and ask you know people on
the street this is what do you think
about post-modernism yeah you know half
of them would say I don't know what the
hell you're talking about post what you
know and then you'd get some who'd be
like oh yeah I've heard about that it's
really bad
you know and you just said well why is
it bad um because they don't believe in
anything or because they're cultural
Marxists or you know this and that and
this and that you know you'd be like
well okay so you mean something
different by post-modernism than what
people who actually work on
post-modernism call post-modernism so
that that's nice
and then you know there's there's all
sorts of other things there's people who
like position themselves as being
postmodern and they see it in a
favorable way but they doesn't see a lot
of art - art students doing this and
they have no conception of what it means
so you know is there is there one single
thing you can look at not really so it's
kind of a non-starter unfortunately I
wouldn't say there's one concept of
post-modernism that's that's part of the
problem as well
kunal writes in 1980 there was a big
debate about Marxist studies of love
thinking about love as a transaction and
so on do you think a sociologist should
use a Marxist lens to study love so I
think that when we're trying to study
something especially a complex human
phenomena we should use multiple
perspectives to do so should I should
somebody exclusively use a Marxist lens
no cuz then you just turn into an
ideologue and you can be just as much of
an ideologue as a Marxist as you can as
I don't know pick whatever thing on the
right you want to complain about you
know you can take anything and become an
ideologue with you be an ideologue
Thomas you can be an ideologue Randian
you can be an ideologue you know high
daguerreian right I think it's really
useful and this is again those were my
philosophical look like Justin comes in
I think it's really useful to look at
things through multiple views so you
know should a a sociologist take into
account Marxist views on things I think
it's smart to do so because Marx himself
didn't get everything right maybe even
didn't get half the things right but
he's certain things that he did get
right he
pretty good on and you know it's not as
if people in the Marxist tradition have
made further contributions after that
and then maybe you know it's also good
to take phenomenological perspectives or
to draw perspectives from ancient
philosophy or you know we can add these
into each other and it doesn't always
have to be a doctrinal dispute you know
but going back to that thing about love
as a transaction I think that in a lot
of cases you know that's a useful lens
for understanding how things go and
that's a sign of their being a problem
right when when you can explain a
relationship I'm not saying all
relationships but a relationship just in
purely transactional terms I mean let's
say you you do that you look at your own
relationship maybe that's a sign that
something needs to get better in your
relationship or or that the relationship
needs to end that's you know I think
that's well worth worth considering
I'm gonna move this a little bit so
lighting is a little bit better there we
go um let me scroll down so here's
here's one it's interesting that that
the questions about like sex and things
are getting held up by YouTube YouTube
is very puritanical about this sort of
stuff so ah Dom asks Missoni estroux
fost said if I'm not mistaken that sex
should be indulged only for the purpose
of having children what do you think
about sex masturbation simply for the
sake of pleasure thank you he actually
says that that that procreation is one
reason for it but and this is you know
this is also a pretty common view you
know among a lot of the virtue ethicists
and also in early Christianity and
Judaism it's also a way for for a couple
to express their love for each other
right to live out that mutual life
together they should be you know engaged
in affection and
and that's you know the physical
affection with each other
I'll give you an interesting this is not
a stoic thing but this is kind of a
biblical story so you know if you ever
think about the story of Samson right
Samson's parents were infertile and so
if the only reason for sex is
procreation they had no business having
sex once they figured out they were
infertile however had they not continued
that there wouldn't have been any a
Samson who's kind of a miracle baby
right plays an important role in the
history and so you know you you can see
that there's there's kind of a
conception that you know sometimes has
to be reaffirmed that it's not just
about making babies you don't want it to
turn it just into a commodity or just
pleasure for for you know purely
detached from many other considerations
but but intimacy could also be equally
valuable and and I think that that's
something that you do see in with
Sonia's Roofus
you do see that in in a lot of you know
religious discussions and you also see
the oh no no no no it's only for him
making babies thing and in a lot of
religious discussions too and I think
this has caused much grief to many
people over time Christian is I was
wondering what do you think about God
does he exist
I actually do believe that that God
exists but I'm not on particularly good
terms with him I'll leave it at that
oh wow two Scotch eggs is representative
politics dead end and it is is it time
for pure democracy well that's that's
there's a whole bunch of questions
contained in there here in the United
States we certainly are in a terrible
situation I think in some places in the
world you there is genuine functioning
representative democracy and I think
that local levels in some places here in
the United States we do have
representative democracy but I think our
national and many of our state political
systems are just so irrevocably damaged
and corrupted by what both the
Republicans and the Democrats and their
supporters have been doing for several
generations that we we don't really have
representative democracy in meaningful
ways except at rare moments the lobbying
industry working for industries has such
a stranglehold on both parties and both
parties has set the system up so that
you know not only are our legislative
districts so gerrymandered in many
places that you know there's absolutely
you know they're non-competitive right
same people just keep going back and
back and back but it's almost impossible
for a third party to break in and you
know the idea that somehow these these
Republican elites and Democratic elites
represent us you know even here in a
swing state like like Wisconsin it's
just ludicrous there's so many obstacles
to genuine representative democracy is
it time for pure democracy
I'm not actually a supporter of pure
democracy myself and I don't see how how
we would have something like that work
you know you know things we've gotten so
complex that I don't know how we would
get that in place and you know the
political elites would never allow that
anyway
so but it's an interesting question ah
DL are there some philosophers or
philosophies that are particularly
studied and discussed them today among
academic philosophers yeah there's
there's a whole slew of them and what's
kind of interesting is it depends on
where you are right so you'll often get
people like say working in the analytic
tradition or like oh you've got to read
this you got to read this people in the
continental tradition are like oh you've
got to read this cutting-edge stuff over
here and you'll be like I never heard of
any of these guys do they have anything
to say about Aristotle
and you know in some places you can't
study classical philosophy and in some
places where you can study classical
philosophy that's the only thing they
let you do they don't do it well so it's
like a patchwork you know there are a
lot of people what is really interesting
is when you see like if you take a
historical approach to things and you
see like there's all these people that
were like hot you know and you know two
centuries ago or a century ago and
everybody had to talk about them and
read them and they were gonna like
revolutionize everything and you
mentioned them today and people like who
are you talking about you know it lends
a little perspective to things so that's
kind of it's kind of cool there's a
funny one from dudes the next time you
do a lesson on eros told iris stole a
scan you call it a Aristotle lesson
that's not a bad idea but it doesn't
really trip off the tongue that well I
think it would take a lot of work so um
Alfredo asks this is sort of a follow-up
to that more sonia's question would
Stoics say the main objective of
marriage is to have kids or where they
say it as another objective he has
multiple objectives like many human acts
right having kids is one of them and not
just having them just as important as
having them is actually taking care of
that nurturing them educating them and
Cicero you know who talks with the the
natural law we you know the natural idea
is partly coming from the Aristotelian
tradition partly from the stoic
tradition and then partly from from
other things as well
Cicero will tell us that you know this
is impulse that we have for making
children is also an impulse to to take
care of them and protect them and
nourish them but it's also between the
the people involved in their
relationship
right intimacy is is a good a marriage
should be from the stoic perspective a
friendship
some people are not really capable of
that because because they haven't worked
through their their issues well enough
or perhaps theirs they're still trouble
struggling with trauma or things like
that but I think there's this is an area
that's that's what we could say
underdeveloped with in stoic teaching
and I've actually started thinking you
know I already have so many different
book projects but this is something that
could really be worth writing about Carl
s have you ever made any dives into
Eastern philosophy Confucius legalism
yeah I mean I usually actually teach
that stuff in in my first full-time
teaching gig both as religion classes
you know I teach world religions pretty
routinely and they'd also teach an
upper-level Eastern religions which sort
of Eastern religion and philosophy but
I'd also teach some Eastern philosophy
classes I had a very strong interest in
Chinese philosophy for a long time but
it's not something I've really pursued
that much in part because my efforts to
learn Mandarin through my own you know
laziness I've never really found it so
much as I'm ashamed to say and then you
know Indian philosophy I've done I've
done a good bit of reading in that but
again I'm here I'm sort of handicapped
in because I don't read Sanskrit you
know or poly I am always a little bit
because I you know I do work in other
languages and I see how sometimes
sketchy the translations can be I know
that I shouldn't just rely on
translations and so and I can't claim a
lot of expertise in that that sort of
thing
veteran Wollo what did the early Stoics
think of christianity we don't have a
lot of references to that as a matter of
fact this I'm the Marcus Aurelius thing
this is something where Donald Robertson
is a good person to to go to because
he's been doing a lot of work historical
work on Marcus and you know Marcus did
persecute Christians it seems at some
points but certainly not on the level
that that it was claimed
and you know Christians were non
conformists epic here Epicurus
Epictetus mentions them as Galileans at
one point but doesn't really say much
about them
so in the Stoics who we have a lot of
writing from there's not a lot that they
have to say about about Christianity as
such you know you got to remember too
that Christianity in the first let's say
the first two centuries is really
underground poorly understood by people
who aren't in the community and then you
start getting a lot of back and forth
you know polemics between say Christians
and pagans but also between you know
like Platonists for example as a thing
against the Gnostics right so he's not
writing as Orthodox Christians is
writing against Gnostics and that most
most people probably the Roman Emperor
were better familiar with Judaism than
they were with Christianity for the
first couple centuries and then you know
then it really takes off you know and
eventually a lot of stoic stuff gets
kind of absorbed same thing with you
know Neoplatonism gets absorbed into
Christian thought so as it's something
really interesting to think about Tim
asks anything on pros and cons of
celibacy or a monk like lifestyle
dedicating your life for Society this
would be later in life after fulfilling
life responsibilities similar to what's
going out and say Hinduism I mean it's
not actually part of the caste system
well you're talking about more would
have to do with like the four aims of
life right you know at first it's about
kama pleasure
artha wealth or security dharma you know
fulfilling one's duties and then
eventually it's about moksha
you know liberation and and you do that
as a retiree ideally I mean that that
can be a good thing I I don't myself I
don't have her envision retiring I'm
probably gonna keep doing this sort of
thing although I don't know what for
man will be and who knows if YouTube is
gonna be around 20-30 years later
provided I live that long but I am I
imagine I'm gonna be doing stuff like
this teaching and coaching and
consulting and you know writing books
and things like that my entire life but
you know is that a good thing for others
to do yeah I mean I I think it's it's
it's great you know monasticism can be a
really useful way of intentional living
for some people so yeah I will say this
that that there's there's a lot of
literature about monks and nuns who
didn't remain celibate and sometimes
would get involved with each other it
was it was kind of a common issue a
common problem throughout history and
across cultures so lowly cama cama voli
asked if i've read the return of philip
lat tin Ovitz
no I haven't read that oh here's a very
good question
one of the Stoics think about animals
should we take care of them should we
use them so this is something I think
we're ancient stoicism and and a modern
approach to sources stoicism should
probably diverge from each other and I'm
actually working on some collaborative
work both in terms of stoicism today and
in terms of some academic writing with
people who are thinking about this so
the ancient Stoics said that you know
animals are non rational non rational
nature is therefore rational nature was
a teleological thing to it would they
have continents something like factory
farming like we do absolutely not though
the cruelty involved is is you know a
horrific scale and it makes us complicit
in in it you know because of the
marketplace that were stuck in unless we
choose to get ethically sourced meat
dairy
eggs those sorts of things which is very
expensive I think they would be against
the ancient folks would be against that
sort of thing but they they you know
they didn't think that animals were
rational it's sort of like with Kahn
right Kahn says listen animals they
don't have the same like rights as human
beings but you can tell a lot about a
person by the way they treat animals
their moral status you know I think now
you know I don't know that we want to
say animals are rational per se but they
sure see they sure do seem to come close
some of them the Apes whales dolphins
crows it looks like perhaps at least in
certain respects octopi perhaps
elephants there's so much more that we
know about animal behavior than we did
back in the day so I think that's
something we might have to revise so uh
space fiction a said I found anything
useful in Humes works yeah I mean I I
think he's you know this notion of
association of ideas is a pretty good
one you know and I actually loved
reading him he's one of these people
sort of like Hobbes you know or I read
them mostly disagree with them but I
kind of like secant to I like seeing how
the structure is laid out and you know I
find some things useful in him here and
there to agree ideological system seen
as systems of propagation as in ones who
encourage high birthrates or plot
proselytizing will become dominant the
Amish will be more relevant than
stoicism because of this effect well
that's that's quite a stretch I mean the
Amish are not like you know rapidly
increasing I'd say latter-day saints
would be more of an issue than an Amish
in that case but I mean it is a very
interesting thing Judaism here in
America is is you know through
generations going to be much less Reform
Judaism and much more
DOX Judaism because it was a great study
on this years back i sees in my
religious studies classes because you
know the the the orthodox have many more
children than the reform or
conservatives do but the other thing you
have to keep in mind is so you talked
about birth rates but in proselytizing
the Amish don't really proselytize right
do modern stoic to proselytize i guess
you could say they do although there's a
lot more like well you know see if you
like this and then we'll talk about it
it's not the hard sell I think the
people doing the hard sell usually the
ones who are just sort of pseudo stoic
so but I mean stoicism is growing at
least in terms of adherence I don't know
that we should look at it necessarily as
a religion right there's there's there's
a great debate going on about that as
well
[Music]
all right dude says I want to have an
opinion about post-modernism but I don't
want to research post-modernism well
then you're probably in the same boat as
most people that's fine you know canal
ass do you think Erich Fromm's
distinction between brotherly love
motherly and fatherly love erotic love
self love and love God are helpful sure
it's been a long time since I've been
reading from I actually got that one
about freedom out there sitting waiting
for me to read but I haven't gotten to
it yet it's been a long time since I've
been there and the art of loving that's
a long time since I've read that I mean
making distinctions is always helpful we
don't want to turn them into absolute
like you know this is this category and
this category want to be you know
attention to how they they connect up
with it
Roberts I had watched ISM how do I get a
girlfriend that's a big question and it
may you know I don't know that the
autism part
necessarily interferes with it I mean
you do the same thing as other people do
I mean that it hey how do you get a
girlfriend well I mean you have to find
somebody who you fight attractive and
who might be attracted to you I'd get to
know them and ask them out and you know
there's a whole bunch of different
things involved and you know everything
there's things to do and not to do like
treat people well and and don't have
high expectations going into things and
you know when you get in the inevitable
fights try to work them out and and you
know the be willing also to say ok maybe
this relationship isn't what I wanted
and I'm gonna leave and find another one
you know so I'd say it's the same thing
as everybody else I mean it's funny cuz
I decided quite a bit about this you
know I'm in my late 40s and I understand
relationships a lot better now as we do
a lot of things as we get older for
paying attention and if I could go back
and tell my you know teen and 20 year
old self advice I don't know if that guy
would actually listen to me first off
but if he did he would have been so much
better off so many things I was anxious
about or sad about or upset about that
that really didn't matter at all so
Rebecca as a beginner in the study of
Stoicism I'm hooked of living by example
is there a good way to raise your
children the stoic from the mind yeah so
there actually is some good literature
about this some of which is in stoicism
today I think you know you don't want to
be like you know pushing stoicism as
such but you can like apply stoic
techniques you know think about like
anxieties that kids go through and then
like you know talk through these
anxieties and get them see that maybe
some of the things that they really are
anxious about they don't have to be
anxious about you generally it's not
going to work like that they'll be less
anxious you know I've done this with my
own kids
and you know we don't say oh the marcus
aurelius says you know or anything like
that but yeah that that sort of thing
can be helpful these sort of techniques
but again you you do have to practice
the dichotomy of control
just because you know it would be good
for your kid to be less anxious and
these techniques are ways to do that
doesn't mean that you you know
presenting them to your kid is
automatically going to your kid to buy
into them and apply them and so you
don't want to be too invested in you
know your kid actually doing it it's
hard to do as a parent right because you
want the best for your kids so uh - what
are some good advice is on relationship
from Ovid you know I would gives you
some great pickup advice oh she's read
the art of love for that I'm gonna start
skipping through these fairly quickly
because they're getting kind of close to
the end cue brief says relationships
that are not transactional don't exist
and if they did they would be
unconditional which marriages are not a
lot of assumptions built into that one
so I'll just point that out and and say
that strikes me as one that you'd
probably want to examine or more closely
oh great question here do you know this
from Kannagi
Kanaga LV do you know any fiction that
portray stoic philosophy accurately um I
do not but I'm sure there's got to be
some out there one of my clients has
been telling me about this this series
that he's been reading that Cicero is
like a main character and and I don't
remember who the author is but there's a
whole series of books out there maybe
those are good there is another book
that I'll mention which was pretty good
but not super great and it was called
of cats and I'm gonna butcher the
author's name max the JNA or something
but if you just look up city of cats so
I I'm actually I never got around to
reviewing it and you know author sent me
a copy and it's it you know it was kind
of heavy-handed at first but it was
pretty good in parts of it was focused
on ancient philosophy okay dude says
another question what do you think the
Stoics would say about the pop culture
today in relation to sex I heard a song
the other day on the radio that said
something obscene right that's not too
hard to hear her makers we're talking
about this my wife and I because we we
watch you know streaming shows we don't
have we don't have regular TV and we
don't have cable we have Amazon fire and
that that means that we you know can
watch Netflix and all that
and we're like yeah you know it's like
you can't do a sci-fi series without
showing a lot of nudity these things can
you you know and it's kind of funny
because like now it's a like all it's
not just like you know the occasional
bare boob or something like that there's
sex scenes they're not like actual
penetration succeeds but you know
they're very very much hinting at it and
there's a lot of full frontal nudity and
you know I mean what would the stoic say
about our contemporary culture and they
would say it was as much of a mess as
the Rome of their day was you know so I
think that's canon kind of an issue I'm
gonna we're at 2:30 now and I actually
do have to do another thing in a little
while for my half hour Hegel patrons so
I'm gonna just pick a few at random
we'll go a little bit over time and I'll
just grab a couple that I might be able
to do fairly quickly
other than stick to ones that are mostly
connected with stoicism what are my
thoughts is from justice on Diogenes the
cynic or of cynicism in general compared
to stoicism you know I think it was I
think of it the way that epictetus did
Diogenes interesting guy
you know if he's to be believed he was a
herald of the gods you know but the role
that he picked is not the role it's not
the way people are supposed to do things
it was just for that guy
you know and most people who are cynics
are actually jerks you know most of the
people who are trying to behave like
Diogenes or just you know we're not in
it for the same reasons that maybe
Diogenes was and you know the epic Judas
has a really long chapter on the calling
of the cynic and he says stuff like
listen you want to be a cynic here's
what it requires you got to do this this
this this and by the way if you can't do
them right don't bother doing them
because people are gonna say boy this
guy's full of crap you know and you
they'll be right about you so unless you
can actually measure up to deities don't
bother trying to be a Diogenes for the
rest of them there's just OA system you
know which is already kind of tough
enough right I know I'm gonna mangle
this name this is Japan is it possible
Stoics took any inspiration from Eastern
religions was there any connection
between ancient Greece Rome in India
China Japan anything is possible
historically likely no not really
if there was any connection it would
have been between India and Greece you
know through the Hellenistic successor
states after Alexander's Empire and
there was some Greek philosophy that was
probably influenced by Indian philosophy
but it wasn't stoicism and there's
people out there that are kind of trying
to sell that that line that it was but
all of those stories are so many like
well it could have been this way and it
could have been this way and it could
have been this way and it could have
been this way and
you know and you look at your like this
is mostly [ __ ] you know it's like
sort of like what the History Channel is
degenerated into now and that's not to
say that you couldn't do comparative
work now between stoicism and things
right so it's Jos ISM and Buddhism or
you've actually got a great article
coming out stoicism today in the coming
months on stoicism and Upanishads but
there's no historical connection between
them
all right let me see scroll down there's
one other one in there about stoicism
there was it aa James
hey what about psychosis and stoicism
I'm unsure about what is that under your
control yeah so this is something where
you know modern Stoics have stressed
that if you have a severe mental illness
that's not something every your control
I mean stoicism definitely can help
let's take that psychosis something you
know very extreme like that but let's
talk about depression right if you
suffer from severe depression and
there's you know there's clinic
clinicians have you know inventories
that they have you fill out
questionnaires to to figure that out
I actually I used to baffle my
psychiatrist who was a very doctrinaire
you know everything fits in its place
kind of guy because he couldn't figure
out whether I was mildly or moderately
depressed at the time because the the
tool that he was using was poorly
designed so if you scored a 50 on it you
might fit into both categories and so he
didn't know what to do
stoicism as a sort of you know therapy
of desire to use nurse bombs phrase or
you know we could talk about other
things as well is not for people who are
who are suffering from absolutely
debilitating mental illnesses I'll give
you an example my I I have an uncle
who's severely bipolar and if he doesn't
have his medication which unfortunately
he didn't have in a good portion of his
life and he lost a lot of good
years because of it he simply can't
function now can you use medication to
like stabilize yourself and then use you
know stoicism or use cognitive behavior
therapy or use Aristotelian virtue
ethics or use some some other thing that
helps you sort of get in there model
what's going on with you work out habit
formation you know the connection
between your emotions and thoughts yes
and those can be very powerful together
I don't know I don't know that if
there's an organic reason for psychosis
that stoicism would be very helpful at
all you know we can say similar to
things like that so I'm going to take
one other question that has some
relation to stoicism this is from unease
we did you have any advice for uni
philosophy students currently trying to
learn at a Greek for help with reading
original non translated texts so yeah
III think it's a you know you want to be
spending as let me put it to you this
way don't just do what they tell you to
do in your course do more because your
goal is not to pass a class your goal is
to be able to read Greek and so you want
to spend a lot of time you know like
doing paradigms even though it's really
boring
and you know if you get yourself a smyth
Greek grammar read through the entries
in there don't don't just sort of skim
to the stuff that's useful acquire as
much knowledge as you can and then the
other thing to remember I think this may
be very helpful this is a nice way to
close it out actually there's there's
one other thing I'll answer very quickly
after that
so each author is going to have their
own vocabulary and some share a lot in
common I mean if you can if you can read
Aristotle you can probably read Apetit
is pretty well
Aristotle's already sort of on the way
to Koine Greek you know and and and but
there's some reading Plato Plato was
pretty tough you need a large lexicon to
read Plato and there's other authors we
could talk about as well don't get
discouraged when it feels like you
almost have to relearn the lang
which over again to go to a new author
that's just this is the way it goes and
and it gets better over time as you
accumulate more and more you will you
know at first when you're studying it's
it feels like you're never gonna
understand say that is Greek
same thing with Latin German any of
these sorts of things but over time
you'll be surprised at just how much you
you learn and eventually get to the
point where you start making mistakes
that are the kind of mistakes that
somebody who actually knows the language
makes and then you know that you're
you're actually really making progress
so just just stick with it and it will
it will get better there were so there's
some people saying hello from lit that's
4chan they they like to make memes about
me every once in a while then people on
Twitter send them to me so that's that's
very nice and somebody had another thing
they asked do I have a well they write
into the table person be able Inc but I
do want to mention a link that that I do
have and probably it would be good for
I'll just you can always google it if
you want so you know that this is
supported by my patreon backers all the
the sort of public domain work that I'm
doing that's that's how I earn my living
and then I've got the business side on
the other part ready to the tutorials
and all that so if you want to support
the work that I'm doing you can go to
patreon.com/scishow or Hegel people and
we'll see what they want to talk about
but very interesting set of questions
and we actually stayed pretty much on
topic this time which we don't always do
so I hope all of you have a great
weekend and I will see you will do
people will be doing another one of
these in Facebook on my Facebook page
right it just tells you
how you get notifications in there
because I'm producing it rather than the
receiving end but we do these monthly I
don't know what the theme is for next
month I see people saying more play-doh
so maybe I'll consider that there's so
many ideas in play-doh that could be fun
to revisit in any case if you haven't
read the the article on modern stone and
stoicism today which is on the modern
stoicism site you might take a look at
that there's some more detailed stuff
about like Stoics and and love and
relationships so if you're into that
sort of thing that might be that might
be good for you to take a look at all
right so long everybody